today's video is brought to you by ag1
from athletic greens the effortless
daily habit that empowers your whole
body's Health more on them later Nazi
Germany has been portrayed as so
cartoonishly evil for so long now that
it's difficult to imagine a time that
they were taken seriously but in 1941
the German Army was considered one of
the best in the world Victorious and all
fronts conquering vast swaths of
territory with Advanced strategies and
tactics suit in Modern Warfare one of
Premier strategist of the German
military owes Erik von manstein manstein
saw better than most anyone else how the
modern weapons and Technology of the
20th century could be used to defeat the
third reich's enemies engineering plans
that would inflict stinging defeats on
Poland France and the Soviet Union and
catapult him to the highest echelons of
the weirmarked after the war was over
manstein attempted to portray his
actions as being patriotic that he and
his soldiers had nothing to do with the
appalling Crimes of the Nazis that they
were just as much victims as those who
had died in the concentration camps for
many years people believed him the
modern research and historical analysis
reveals this to be a lie the truth was
manstein was emblematic of an officer
cast to enable the rise of Adolf Hitler
supported and encouraged his plans and
were more than happy to accept honors
and privileges at his hand manstein
would be loyal to the regime to The
Bitter End even when Hitler himself had
turned on him and his post-war
whitewashing of his involvement in some
of the war's worst atrocities should be
seen for what it is a self-serving
attempt to explain away why one of the
most gifted commanders of his era
allowed himself to fall under the sway
of a deranged Madman
foreign
Lewinski was born in 1887 in Berlin the
son of a Prussian artillery General
because the Lewinsky's already had nine
children and Helen Von Lewinsky's sister
Hedwig and her husband George Von
manstein were unable to have children
Eric was adopted at Birth by his aunt
and uncle a common practice at the time
his adoptive father was also a general
and another Uncle Paul Von Hindenburg
would later attain the rank of field
martial during the first world war in
all over 30 of his relatives were
Military Officers many of them are
reaching high rank part of a
aristocratic Prussian military tradition
that dated back to the Middle Ages it
would have been frankly more surprising
if manstein had not grown up to become a
soldier considering the family business
that he was born into and so it seemed
only the normal course of events that
Jan Eric was commissioned as an officer
in 1906 into the Imperial German army of
Kaiser Wilhelm II he first saw action in
the first world war being wounded twice
and rising to the rank of Captain but he
could do nothing but stomach the
humiliation of defeat at the hand of the
Allies in 1918 alongside his comrades
with the monarchy abolished the new
Weimar Republic was restricted in the
Treaty of Versailles to an army of a
hundred thousand of which only four
thousand could be officers such as
Captain manstein's ability and family
connections that he was chosen as one of
the very few veterans to make the
transition to the post-war react sphere
he was still there in 1933 when Adolf
Hitler and the Nazis came to power and
like most of his fellow officers
manstein supported Hitler because of his
promises to re-militarize Germany and
restore the glory of the nation Glory
that had been stripped from them at the
end of the war manstein and the German
officers cast many of them coming from
Prussian noble families where an
inherently conservative Bunch they had
prospered under the monarchy and were
not fans of the democratization of the
country above all they feared a
Communist Revolution like what had
happened in Russia in 1917 seeing it as
a great threat to the German meaning
their way of life therefore they saw
Hitler as a way to return things to the
way they were supposed to be in turn
Hitler needed the Army if he was to
achieve his radical Ambitions to make
Germany the dominant European and world
power thurixver rebranded in 1935 as the
Mark and was declared by him to be one
of the pillars of the new Third Reich
alongside his National Socialist
ideology today's video is brought to you
by 81 from athletic greens a nutritional
drink that completely changes your
Wellness routine like it changed mine
look I'm a busy person and I need
something that's quick and easy and
covers all of my nutritional needs and
that's where ag1 comes in it's made with
75 of the highest quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Foods horse nutrients
in the world you can see them all are
big list on the back there plus it
combines nine Health Products working
together as one replacing multivitamin
multi-mineral pre and probiotic immunity
support and more I've been taking 81 for
a while now it's been probably a couple
of years since they've been sponsoring
me and it's been a game changer I
typically have it in the morning with my
coffee it's uh the afternoon now so I
made myself up a second all you have to
do is you take one scoop you put it in
here you shake it up and you're good to
go it tastes great as well it's very
green but it tastes vanillary
pineappally it's uh it's tasty
and I have a special offer for you all
you need to do is head to
athleticreens.com biographics or click
the link in the description below and
you'll get a one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D3 and five travel
packs as well so you can stay healthy on
the go so don't wait any longer try ag1
from athletic greens today there's a
link below and now back to today's video
the new regime was good for the military
and for Eric Von manstein's career as he
went from a lieutenant colonel in 1933
to a lieutenant general in 1939. every
move Hitler made in those years marching
troops into the Rhineland the annexation
of Austria the occupation of
Czechoslovakia was supported by manstein
who believed this was nothing more than
restoring Germany's historic boundaries
the same attitude existed towards Poland
believed to be an artificially created
country that needed to be restored to
German control have Great Britain and
France acting as guarantors of Poland
sovereignty threatened war with Germany
if they invaded their Eastern neighbor
after the war ended manstein and other
surviving generals would claim that
they'd been forced into war by Hitler's
order that they had cautioned against
invading Poland however the evidence
shows that the Veer marked High command
had been preparing for case whites as
the occupy code named since the spring
of 1939 following the occupation of
Czech Slovakia the generals manstein
included were enthusiastic about war
with Poland predicting that the Western
allies were bluffing with their threats
the real threat in their view was the
Soviet Union which was neutralized in
August by the announcement of a
non-aggression pact between Hitler and
Soviet dictator Joseph Stalin but
included a secret agreement to divide
the conquered polish Territory between
them what happened next is well known
Germany invaded Poland on September the
1st starting World War II two days later
Great Britain and France declared war on
Germany it was NOW essential to finish
the conquest of Poland before the
Western allies mobilized their armies as
most of Germany's generals believed that
they didn't have the resources to fight
a two-front war to accomplish this the
Vermont would turn to new theories of
War advocated by officers like manstein
and general Heinz guderian mobile
Warfare differed from the way military
campaigns had been conducted for
centuries which relied on the occupation
of territory and strong points like
fortresses to defeat the enemy instead
striving to defeat the enemy's Armed
Forces through a war of maneuver this
would come to fruition in Poland through
the Blitzkrieg or lightning war in which
the Vermont rushed forward divisions of
fast-moving tanks called panzers by the
Germans which were supported by wave
upon wave of aerial bombing runs on
enemy formations and cities the poles
never stood a chance especially not once
the Soviets attacked them from behind
and the campaign was over in a month
foreign
their attention to France where the
Allied armies were mobilizing this was
considered to be a much tougher fight
than in Poland most of the generals were
First World War veterans and remembered
well the horrific fighting on the
Western Front the French had fortified
their border with Germany with imagino
line a series of strong fortifications
that was considered impregnable the
Allies believed that the Germans would
attack just as they did in the last war
by invading Belgium so that is where
they placed their best troops initially
the German war plans called for just
that with only one big descending voice
General manstein manstein believed that
he had a better idea an attack through
the heavily forested our den region
believed to be by both sides impossible
to tanks by making the main thrust
through the Arden the Germans could then
sweep up behind the bulk of the Allied
armies in Belgium trapping them in a
pincer which would inevitably lead to
their destruction the only problem was
none of manstein's immediate superiors
like this plan the high command of the
Vermont was filled with personalities
that were all competing for the favor of
the fuhrer which usually necessitates
stepping on each other his bosses
refused forward manstein's alternate
plan to Hitler and when he persisted he
arranged for him to be removed from his
post as Chief of Staff to one of the
attacking Army groups in the west the
manstein got the last laugh on his way
to his new assignment he was given a
private audience with Hitler and
successfully convinced him of the merits
of the Arden plan Hitler altered the
plan to change a decision that would
have faithful consequences the sickle
cut attack through the Arden took the
Allies completely by surprise even the
Germans were shocked by how successful
their attack was in a matter of weeks
the Germans had destroyed over 60
British and French divisions with a loss
of over 300 000 men killed or captured
the victory was not as complete as it
could have been however thanks to a
nervous Hitler calling for his panzers
to Halt for two days in order to
resupply the Allies were therefore able
to organize the miracle of Dunkirk the
successful evacuation of over 300 000
troops including most of the British
expeditionary Force no one seemed to
care very much at the time however
France would be forced to capitulate on
the 25th of June and was put under
German occupation the humiliation of the
first world war had been Avenged and
though Hitler himself would claim credit
for the victory everyone in the wehr
marked knew that the victory had been
orchestrated by a general who wasn't
even part of the attack Eric Von
manstein
Great Britain was now alone facing the
Germans but initial plans for invading
the island called Operation Sea Lion
over shelved because of the superiority
of the British royal Navy and the
inability of the German luftwaffe to
gain control of the Skies over the
English Channel instead the eyes of the
Germans turned to the country they
believed was their Real Enemy all along
the Soviet Union Hitler viewed conflict
with Stalin as being inevitable since
the Communist system was set up as the
diametric opposite of the National
Socialist one according to Nazi ideology
thanks to propaganda and conspiracy
theories most Germans believed that the
Red Revolution had been instigated by
Jews as part of a plot to take over the
world and that unless they were dealt
with they would eventually spread their
ideology to Germany and the rest of
Europe it wasn't just a question of
ideology though but also of race the
Slavic people who lived in Poland and
the USSR were considered unto mentioned
by the Nazis or sub-humans who didn't
deserve the land and natural resources
that they had the ultimate goal of the
Nazi regime was to conquer vast tracks
of land in Eastern Europe known as
leban's Rome living space for the German
Aryan race to populate which would
guarantee them a stable and successful
future as the dominant country in Europe
if not the entire world as other people
already lived there well they'd have to
be removed one way or another unless
they could be made to serve their new
German Masters for the Nazis War the
Russians were seen as a climactic clash
of West versus East the culmination of
centuries of conflict and had been
planned as far back as 1939 prior to the
invasion of Poland Operation Barbarossa
began on June 22 1941 when 3.8 million
German and Allied troops invaded the
Soviet Union the largest Invasion force
in history General manstein as the head
of the invasion Force commanded a Panza
Corps in Army Group North which was
tasked with occupying the Baltic States
before advancing on Leningrad today
Saint Petersburg Russia's Second City on
September 12th he was informed that he
was promoted to command of the 11th Army
which was part of the army group South
fighting in Ukraine he arrived at his
new command five days later replacing
General von shobert been killed in a
plane crash 11th Army's task was to
conquer the Crimean Peninsula including
the Fortress of savastapol which was
considered to be one of the strongest in
the world the problem with the Crimean
Peninsula was that it was so narrow the
kinds of wide-ranging flank assaults
that Manchester specialized in just
weren't possible instead the series of
bloody frontal assaults traded ground
for the lives of his soldiers until he'd
taken control of most of Crimea and put
Sebastopol Under Siege the Red Army
counter-attacked making sea-based
Landings on the Kirch peninsula in the
East able to hold off manstein through
superiority and numbers and by
dominating the Skies over the
battlefield the following spring and
Dean launched an offensive Battle of the
Kirch Peninsula that swept the Soviets
off of Crimea inflicting a massive
defeat on them over 160 000 men were
killed or captured along with 250 tanks
and over a thousand artillery pieces
Mountain then turned back towards
Sebastopol with air support from the
luftwaffe as well as an intimidating
array of artillery support this included
one of the largest guns ever built the
schwera Gustav a massive Beast that
weighed over 13 tons with a barrel
longer than the height of a 10-story
building it could fire an 800 millimeter
projectile at a Target over 40
kilometers away and was so big that
railroad tracks had to be built in front
of it in order to move it by the 4th of
July 1942s of astapar had been leveled
by the artillery and bombing barrage and
the Germans had control of the city in
appreciation of his achievement Hitler
notified man to stay in the same day
that it was to be promoted to field
Marshal the German Army's highest rank
it was to prove the height of his
military career
foreign
the war between the Germans and the
Soviets on the Eastern Front the largest
military confrontation in history was
fought very differently from Germany's
campaigns against the Western countries
contemporary evidence indicates that
most of the Vermont soldiers believed
the propaganda that their enemies were
little better than animals they were
encouraged by their Russian superiors to
treat Russian and polish civilians
savagely into blanket immunity from
prosecution for all crimes against
civilians was issued prior to the
invasion training behind the Army were
SS death squads called einsatzgruppen
who were tasked with murdering enemies
of other state among the conquered
civilian population and captured Red
Army soldiers including Jews Muslims
political commissars and members of the
Communist Party infrastructure Soviet
prisoners of War were not treated in
accordance with the Geneva Convention
but instead deliberately penned up an
inadequate prison camps exposed to the
elements and starved it is estimated
that over 2 million Soviet prisoners
died in captivity in the first year of
War mostly from malnutrition and disease
as well as the brutality of their
captors after the war mandine and other
generals would insist that they had
known nothing about the the atrocities
and war crimes committed during the
conflict but this has been shown to be a
lie the iron sights group and were
ordered to work closely with the Army
units and issued regular reports of
their activities manstein like almost
every other German general in the
theater knew exactly what was occurring
behind the lines and either ignored it
or encouraged it the War Began to go
badly for the Germans in the last half
of 1942 as the Soviets began marshalling
their Massive Internal resources along
with considerable material help from the
United States and Great Britain Russian
generals were now also wise to the
tactics of the beer marked and were able
to prevent the kind of Open Country
flank attack that banstein was famous
for from hurting them anymore the
Germans meanwhile had Advanced too far
on too wide of a front and couldn't hold
all the territory it gained making
things worse Hitler began to assume more
and more day-to-day control of the
wehrmach's activities and his amateurish
decisions such as his no retreat order
forbidding the yielding of a single
inter-captured territory even if the
military situation demanded it it was
starting to hurt Field Marshal manstein
was transferred back to the northern
front leading a failed attempt to
capture Leningrad which had resisted a
year-long Siege by this point and was
also unable to reach the surrounded
German sixth Army at Stalingrad today
Volgograd which would eventually be
forced to surrender in February 1943
with a loss of 300 000 men despite now
being outnumbered by the Red Army the
Germans went on the offensive one more
time in 1943 with manstein attempting to
flank a section of Soviet defenses in
and around the city of Kursk the Battle
of Kursk was the largest tank battle in
history involving almost 10 000 armored
vehicles including the new German tiger
and panther tanks the Germans inflicted
twice as many casualties as they
sustained during the fighting but the
losses that we are marked suffered could
not be replaced while the Soviets were
mustering more and more soldiers to the
front every day
foreign
and many of the other generals now
privately realized that it was no longer
possible to win the war against the
Soviets but no one could convince Hitler
who believed himself to be a military
genius to see reason manstein was one of
the few that dared try arguing
unsuccessfully with the fuhrer several
times to change his strategy and
tactical deployments all this did was
make Hitler distrust the man he and most
everyone else recognized as Germany's
best strategist had Germany been led by
a more rational man it is likely that
the field Marshal would have been
appointed commander-in-chief of the army
a post that manstein opened the coveted
but Hitler no longer trusted anyone's
judgment but himself preparing to
surround himself with men that would
follow his orders without question no
matter how insane the end of manstein's
military career came on March 30th 1944
when he was relieved of command in favor
of field Marshal modal despite his
qualms about the way the war was being
won he remained loyal to Hitler to The
Bitter End refusing to have any part of
the conspiracy of officers led by clars
Von stavenberg to assassinate the fuhrer
he continued to arrogantly believe that
Hitler wouldn't dare to leave a man with
his military capabilities on the
sidelines forever and that eventually
he'd be restored to command with the
Allies closing in on Berlin from all
sides but it was not to be on May 7 1945
with Hitler dead and the German Army
surrendering manstein became a prisoner
of British Field Marshal Berner
Montgomery he would remain a British
prisoner until 1953 being convicted of
war crimes in a highly contentious 1949
trial but it only served a few years of
his 18-year sentence before being let go
the reason for his early release was the
looming cold war between the west and
the Soviet Union as well as a myth
started and maintained by manstein
foreign 's Memoirs published in 1955 who
went into extensive detail on the war
itself criticizing Hitler's decisions as
being the reason the war was lost but
was suspiciously mum on the racial and
ideological politics behind the war in
Russia as well as the criminal actions
taken during it he had insisted during
the Nuremberg trials that the wehrmacht
had behaved honorably during the war
that all the atrocities had been
committed by the Nazis and their secret
police because the Western allies had
experienced this honorable conduct when
fighting the Germans themselves they
tended to believe the general since the
ones arguing the loudest about war
crimes in the East or with a Soviets who
other West was growing to increasingly
distrust they tended to dismiss Soviet
claims of massacres and brutality as
being exaggerations or outright lies the
truth was the West needed to rearm the
half of Germany occupied by them after
the war as part of NATO's defensive
strategy against the soviet-led Warsaw
Pact they needed Soldiers with
experience to make up the newly
constituted bundas there which would
have to come from earmarked veterans
including manstein who served as an
advisor to the West German Chancellor in
the 1950s on how best to rebuild
Germany's army so it was far easier to
dismiss the outrages of World War II on
a few insane leaders almost completely
ignoring the complicity with which the
entire German Army and by extension the
country itself were completed in
wholesale Slaughter and genocide it
would take decades for the extent of the
weirmark's participation in the war
crimes at the Eastern Front to be
acknowledged mostly coming after the
fall of Communism and the reunification
of Germany in 1990. historical documents
and reports show that vermark soldiers
assisted the SS and secret police in
conducting massacres of civilians and
prisoners as well as providing
logistical support for the einsatz group
and to do their grisly work they were
also in charge of the Soviet prisoners
of war and therefore responsible for
their Grievous treatment it is believed
that as many as 10 million Russian women
were raped by German soldiers and
extensive historical analysis indicates
that almost every German Soldier on the
Eastern Front participated in at least
one criminal act as for Eric Von
manstein he lived a largely quiet life
in West Germany dying in 1973 at the age
of 85 5. it was buried with military
honors being described as a brilliant
soldier who had been misled by a blind
sense of Duty but this like the clean
Veer marked there's nothing more than a
myth cultivated by manstein himself the
truth is the general was a brilliant
Soldier but he was also ruthlessly
ambitious and saw no problem with Waging
War on an unprecedented scale in order
to secure his own advancement he was
perfectly happy to follow Hitler's
orders for the most part as long as the
tributes and the rewards kept coming in
it was only after the war ended and he
needed to talk his way out of trouble
that he would blame everything on his
old Master conveniently absolving
himself of all responsibility in the
process in a way manstein's story is a
tragic one A Tale of a brilliant man who
allowed himself to be led into doing the
devil's work in exchange for the
Fulfillment of his dreams who probably
didn't realize how deep it gotten
himself until it was too late to get out
but any tragedy is overshadowed by the
fact that he never turned against Hitler
even when Hitler turned against him and
after the war he cynically took
advantage of World War tensions to get
himself off the hot seat going to his
grave having never admitted to doing
anything wrong which is why it is likely
that history will forever remember Field
Marshal manstein as Hitler's General
whether it like that or not